Das Podcast-Dufo ist wieder am Start. Das Podcast-Dufo mit Florentin und Stefan. Vielen Dank an Marian für dieses fantastische Intro, das erste Intro des Jahres 2022. Nein, wir werden diese Woche schon eine Folge dieses Jahr. Aber ja, toller Jahresanfang, herzlichen Glückwunsch auch an alle, die uns jetzt Mitte August des nächsten Jahres hören und unsere Neujahresstimmung nicht verstehen können, die völlig einfach normal ihrem Alltag fröhen, in der Mitte des Lebens angekommen sind und gar nicht diese frische Neuanfangsstimmung genießen können, die wir heute versprühen werden. Hallo. Na ja, es ist ein bisschen auch Orientierungslosigkeit immer dabei. Also es schwingt halt so ein bisschen so neue Energie, wir starten ins neue Jahr, Leute gehen ins Fitnessstudio, Leute machen sich fit, Leute setzen ihre Neujahrsresolutions um. Aber es ist auch ein bisschen immer Orientierungslosigkeit. Was ist anders? Also irgendwie, man muss sich erst im neuen Jahr so ein bisschen zurechtfinden.
Ich habe meine Stimme noch nicht gefunden.
Meine Stimme ist noch nicht angekommen.
Und wie schnell kann man auch mit dem letzten Jahr abschliessen?
Bei dir war ja das letzte Jahr ein sehr gutes Jahr.
Du hast ja Torwon Smalltalker des Jahres, Stefan Zietze.
Und den lokalen Tennis-Round gewonnen und Schach verloren.
Das ist natürlich die Frage, wie lange darfst du da jetzt noch drauf einzahlen?
Also Smalltalker des Jahres 2021, wie lange in 2022 darfst du davon jetzt noch zehren? Oder verbleibt es einfach zurück? Das war wirklich nochmal 31. Dezember, 23.40 Uhr wurde dir der Preis überreicht. Du musstest schnell los, aber du hast es gut gemacht. Ich musste schnell los, aber ich habe mich gut rauslaviert. Mit meinen Smalltalk-Künsten habe ich es geschafft, da irgendwie gut rauszukommen aus der ganzen Nummer. Die Aftershow-Party dieser Veranstaltung war cool, also war echt fantastisch. Viele Gespräche, die einfach sehr gut liefen. Ja. Das hat man bei anderen Partys immer das Gefühl, so schwierig. Also die Rubik's Cube-Aftershow-Party ist tendenziell immer eher ein bisschen trocken. Ja, sehr, sehr froh. Aber die Smalltalker des Jahresabschlussfeier, die ist fantastisch.
Da hat man wirklich eine gute Zeit, man lacht die ganze Zeit.
Vor allem natürlich, weil die Zweit- und Drittplatzierten auch natürlich beweisen wollen, dass sie eigentlich hätten gewinnen sollen.
Dass sie eigentlich besser sind.
Und dass sie sich wegen noch mal mehr reinhängen und einfach den besten Smalltalk, die um die Ohren hauen.
Also das sind die besten Gespräche über Wetter und Immobilien, die du je geführt hast.
Noch spannender prinzipiell als Veranstaltung und Preisverleihung finde ich ja eigentlich die Afershowparty. Die vom Comedypreis erstaunlich nüchtern und trocken. Ja, trocken. So wie ich sie wahrgenommen habe. Kaum ein Schmunzeln in Sicht, nichts dergleichen. Lange Schlangen vor der Currywurstbude, aber ansonsten gar nichts. Viel Hass, Ärgernis auch gegeneinander. Warum hat die gewonnen, warum hat der gewonnen, warum habe ich nicht ich gewonnen? Ja, wenn man so vorbeiläuft an Gesprächen, ja, Brainpool ist alles ein, ist ja zugeschustert hier. Also das sind so diese Wortfeste, die einem so entgegenfliegen. Unverdient. Also, nicht jetzt diese lustige Feier, die man erwartet hätte, wo alle Schreien am Boden liegen, wie dieser Monty Python Sketch mit dem tödlichen Witz.
So stellt man sich ja eigentlich die Comedy-Play-Aftershow-Party vor. Wohingegen, ich glaube, so eine Podcast-Aftershow-Party stelle ich mir ganz gut vor. Ja, ich habe jetzt alle gut reden. Ja, absolut. Ich bin jetzt ein bisschen eingetaucht in die Welt des Scrabble, des professionellen Scrabble. Es gab ja letztes Jahr dieses Scrabble-Event bei Rocket Beans TV, wo ich mich auch mal wirklich sehr intensive 40 Minuten mit dem Thema Scrabble beschäftigt habe. Nicht lange, aber dafür sehr intensiv. Und belohnt wurde ich mit dem sofortigen Ausscheiden aus dem Turnier in der ersten Runde. Aber es sieht sich ein bisschen durch, dass du immer sofort Ausscheiden aus den Turnieren, die Rocket Beans veranstaltet. Also Schach, bist du glaube ich auch keine Runde weitergekommen?
Ja, gegen einen sehr übermüdeten Kontrahenten, der meinte, er hat zwei Stunden geschlafen und mich komplett abgezogen hat. Hast du eine Antwort, dass du sehr gut geschlafen hast und sehr fit und wach bist? Gut vorbereitet, perfekt, gerade nochmal einen schönen Smoothie getrunken und ich bin in der Form meines Lebens und verloren. Aber auch diese Scrabble-Welt, glaube ich, ist auch interessant, diese Scrabble-Turnier-Aftershow-Party, wo einfach diese super wortgewandten Leute, die einfach alle Wörter der Welt kennen und alles buchstabieren und einfach wie buchstabierst du das, wie machst du das, mit PH, die englische Variante oder die amerikanische Variante? Und einfach, du weißt alles, es ist grossartig. Ja, aber auch ein bisschen nervig, dass sie nie einfach sagen, was sie denken, sondern es irgendwie komplexer sagen als nötig.
Das ist natürlich beim Strabble-Event ein bisschen blöd, also man hat das Gefühl, Dinge, die einfach gesagt werden können, werden doof gesagt.
Also irgendwie unzu, zu kompliziert, weil man halt Punkte erreichen will.
Und auch immer diese Punktewerte direkt im Kopf so, ah, das waren jetzt 40 Punkte.
Das ist beim Kompetenpreis, wenn man sagen, kannst du mir das Hühnchen geben, die würden sagen, könntest du mir das ornithologische Erzeugnis händigen.
Oh, händigen, 32 Punkte, nicht schlecht.
Da habe ich mir auch ein paar Sketch-Ideen gehabt, ich kann sie dir präsentieren, weil wir keine Sketch-Show mehr haben.
Wie die Guste in diesem Sinne nochmal an Funk.
Jetzt einfach in der weniger lustigeren Wortform.
Scrabble-Weltmeisterschaft, Finale und jemand hat nur obszöne Wörter auf dem Brett. Das wäre ein Sketch. Unter anderem obszön. Der andere hat obszön und legt, nimmt es O deines Fötzchens und macht obszön draus. Und man denkt sich, okay, interessantes Gespräch. Interessante, genau, interessante Kommentierung meiner Wörter. So was zum Beispiel. Boring. Ich finde die ganze Zeit so Käse und Loch und du sagst, langweilig. Langweilig, Brillenschlange. Und der andere, Moment mal, setz die Brille ab, echauffiert, Krümel im Mund, am Mund, Zahnpasta. War eine Idee, okay, nee, finde ich gut. Nee, kann man gute zwei Minuten daraus machen. Soll ich mal ein bisschen Öl ins Feuer gießen? Bitte. Lass das Öl ins Feuer gießen. Rein da, rein da. Öl ist ein gutes Wort, weil du kriegst deine Öl schnell raus. Aber insgesamt wahrscheinlich nur drei Punkte oder vier. Ganz wenig Punkte, es sei denn, dein Öl ist auf einem guten Feld. Dann kriegst du mal drei oder so, dann hast du richtig Geld. Diese Sonderheiten kenne ich nicht so richtig. Ne, weil du meintest, wir haben keine Sketchshow mehr. Weißt du noch, dass wir nicht sagen durften, dass wir abgesetzt werden? Nur mal so ein kleiner Funfact in die Welt da draußen. Journalisten, macht damit, was ihr wollt. Aber ich erinnere mich noch an den Moment, wo wir abgesetzt wurden, aber nicht sagen durften, dass wir abgesetzt wurden. Und dieser Pressetext war wie so ein Tabuspiel, wo er sagt, dass ihr abgesetzt werdet, ohne das Wort abgesetzt. Hatten wir nicht diese Geschichte, dass unser Studio von einer Lawine erfasst wurde und wir deswegen nicht mehr weitermachen? Haben wir nicht lange versucht, noch diese Lawinen-Story aufrechtzuerhalten? Wir haben versucht, eine Lawinen-Story zu erzählen und das Ganze ein bisschen noch spannend zu kreieren, aber das war auch wieder klar. Ja, dann kam hier der Fokus mit seinen Satellitenfotos und hat wieder gesagt, nee, nee, nee, Freundchen, hier ist keine Lawine. Da gab es keine Lawine in Köln. Hier gab es keine Lawinen. Seit 1904. Dann haben wir gesagt, Schlamm, haben wir Schlamm angelegt noch für 30 Punkte. Das Wort Schlamm-Lawine. Schlamm-Lawine, ach so, sag das doch gleich. Dann haben die alle Zallte-Düten wieder zurückgepfiffen, wieder nach Hause geholt und dann war alles in Ordnung. Das war Stefans Öl ins Feuer Rubrik, die jetzt neu gestartet ist. Ab jetzt giesse ich jede Woche Öl ins Feuer. Okay. Ich weiß noch nicht, wo rein und in welches Feuer und ob ich mich da nicht selber dran verbrenne. Sozusagen in die Lawine noch Öl. Also du machst sozusagen eine Lawine und auf der Lawine entsteht eine zweite Lawine. Du hast eine Lawine zweiter Ordnung. Ich verstehe Lawinen nicht. Ich schon. Also muss ich auch mal klar dagegen halten. Klar, man schmückt sich heutzutage oft mit Halbwissen, aber ich weiss schon, was eine Lawine ist, denn ich bin ein Kind der Berge. Ja, richtig. Ich war jetzt auch über den Jahreswechsel in den Bergen unterwegs und da ist Lawinen und Steinschlag natürlich das Thema Nummer eins, Gesprächsthema Nummer eins, da ging wieder eine runter, raunt man sich zu, wenn man sich auf dem Wanderweg begegnet, ja, da ging wieder, da ist so ordentlich was runter, käme und dann weiß man, oh, oh, oh, nee, nee, nee, ich weiß nicht, ist das ein grösseres Problem? Machen wir die Lawinen nicht grösser, als sie ist? Also reden wir da nicht so häufig drüber und gibt es nicht so viele überproportional viele Filme drüber, dass man denkt, die wären ein grosses Problem, aber eigentlich kommt so einmal in zehn Jahren eine Runde? Ja, dann gib mir doch mal deine Top 10 der Lawinenfilme. Wenn du das jetzt anprangerst, dass es zu viele Filme mit oder über Lawinen gibt, dann will ich jetzt mal wirklich Titelsprechen. Downfall. Okay, das ist natürlich eine Menge. Avalanche 1 bis 8. Das ist natürlich eine Menge, aber ja, nein, es ist ein ernstes Problem. Mit Zach Woods. Aber man hat ja gut gekontert mit den Lawinenhunden, die ausgebildet sind. Deren einziger Job ist es, in einer Lawine zu helfen, wo natürlich auch immer hier in der Hinterhand steht, Falls Flag Lawine, inwiefern lösen die die nicht aus, damit die schön mal wieder raus können. Du meinst, dass die unterbeschäftigten Lawinenhunde aktiv mit ihren Bellen-Genbergen dafür sorgen, dass mehr Lawinen unterkommen, als müssten sie eigene Jobs haben und ihre Lawinen-Leckerlis weiterfinanziert werden. Damit die Ski bekommen. Die wollen schon lange, das ist deren Forderung, die Lawinenhunde wollen Ski, aber die Bergwacht sagt, nein, braucht ihr nicht, ihr kommt auch mit den Pfötchen zurecht, 62 Punkte, und dann sagen die, nein, nein, nein, wir wollen unsere Skier haben und deswegen werden Lawinen ausgelöst, das ist ein Riesenproblem, das ist ein Riesenproblem.
Wie würdest du am ehesten eine Lawine auslösen?
Stampfen.
Du wolltest stampfen?
Herunterpoltern. Es ist glaube ich eine menschgemachte Freude, wenn man auf dem Berg steht, Steine herunterkugeln zu lassen. Es ist ein schöner Anblick und es ist glaube ich die Hauptunterhaltung früherer Menschenvölker gewesen, Steine den Berg herunterrollen zu lassen. Und damit ist die Lawine, die Lawine ist natürlich so eine Art Domino Day für Steinzeitmenschen. Du hast so eine Kettenreaktion, da passiert richtig was Grosses. Wie viele Steine sind dieses Jahr im Fluss gelandet,
so mehr als das letzte Jahr,
so riesen Ding, dann hast du die Werbeunterbrechung, wo der eine kleine Kiesel dann da ewig
im Kreis und dann rollt er wieder weiter.
Genialste Idee.
Brillant. Allerzeiten. Kann man immer wieder erwähnen.
Weil es ist die Frage, und ich glaube,
dass die, man denkt so, ah, am Ende
hatten diese Idee. Ne, ich glaube, die kam ganz am Anfang,
weil wir übertragen, wir wollen eine Kettenreaktion im Fernsehen übertragen. Wie kriegen wir das hin? Wie kriegen wir das hin? Weil es gibt ja Werbeunterbrechungen, und wie kriegen wir das hin, das zu erzählen, ohne dass wir grosse Teile der Kettenreaktion nicht vergessen zu übertragen oder nicht übertragen können? Und dann kam irgendwann diese Idee mit dem Pendel, ich glaube, dann haben sie gesagt, die Macher, ja okay, jetzt wird ein Schuh draus. Dieser Domino-Pendel war genial, aber halt auch oft, ich erinnere mich noch deutlich, dass ich zweimal, man kam aus der Werbung zurück und es lief schon weiter, im Sinne von, Entschuldigung, es lief schon weiter während der Werbung der Umrechnung, da hat das Pendel versagt. Was mich mal verwirrt hat, dass auch wenn das Pendel ging, also wir reden vom Domino-Day, wenn es in die Werbung geht, für alle, die es nicht wissen, kann man die nochmal nachgucken eigentlich?
Mega geil, dann liegt es so ein Zusammenschnitt, nur mit dem Pendel, was langsam in die Mitte gependelt wird, also quasi eine Unterbrechung, ein Delay der Kettenreaktion. So ein Nadelöhr, wenn das hakt, dann ist der ganze Day kaputt.
Nee, eben nicht. Weil selbst in Momenten des Pendels oder in ruhigen, stillen Momenten hat man im Hintergrund dieses kleine Rauschen, Meeresrauschen in meinen Ohren, dieses ineinanderfallende Dominosteine gehabt. Es ging immer an eine Safety Line. Es ging immer nebenan eine Safety Line herum. Wow. Ja, das ist fantastisch. Und deswegen glaube ich, hätte das nichts verursacht. Dem auch regelmäßig dann Rekorde gebrochen.
Ja, Kettenreaktionen ist irgendwie was Tolles, so dieses einmal Anstoßen. Ich kann das total gut nachvollziehen.
Lawinen sind was Tolles.
Lawinen sind was Tolles und eine kleine Lawine für zu Hause vielleicht. Ich habe gerade Wäsche gewaschen und allein die Vorstellung, dass jetzt zu Hause das trocknet, alles aufgehangen, alles genau ausgebreitet und ich weiß, ohne dass ich jetzt was tue, ich habe so diesen Prozess angestossen. Und ich weiß, dass sich jetzt da was tut. Und das ist einfach ein tolles Gefühl. So auch so Downloads, wenn man mal so einen Download macht und dann geht man einkaufen und man weiss zu Hause, da läuft der Download. Es geht weiter. Es geht weiter, da passiert was im Hintergrund, da brodet was. Bist du auch jemand, wie ich, der andauernd mittlerweile was im Hintergrund laufen haben muss, wenn du so allein in deiner Wohnung bist und du gehst mal irgendwo hin zum Kühlschrank oder sowas? Ja. Läuft dann etwas weiter oder nimmst du manchmal wie ich auch den Laptop einfach in der Hand mit? Nee, ich hatte Bluetooth-Kopfhörer, aber ab und zu habe ich dann auch extra Sachen dafür. Also zum Abspülen sage ich jetzt nochmal Sugar Babes ran. Jetzt nochmal ein Album Sugar Babes nochmal durchballern einfach. Das ist für mich, beim Abwaschen gehört das einfach dazu. Overload ist einfach immer noch ein guter Song, kann man auch nichts dagegen sagen. Overload ist der beste Song. Es ist der beste Song vielleicht, ja. Top Ten Sugar Babes Songs? Wow. Round Round und Overload. Das sind meine Sicht, die sich abwechselnd wie eine Lavine. Alle geraden sind Round Round und die Ungeraden sind damit eins in Overload. Okay. Bei dir? Ja, dir auch. Okay. Also, das sind die beiden Songs. Gut, dass wir keinen Sugar Babes Podcast gemacht haben, sonst sässen wir spätestens jetzt bei Folge 291 ziemlich in der Tinte. Und ich weiß noch auch, wie das der Plan war eigentlich. Ja, ursprünglich war das der Plan, wir konnten uns aber nicht einigen zwischen Destiny's Babes und Sugarcreens, konnten wir uns nicht einigen, was wir machen wollen, deswegen haben wir gesagt, nee, dann machen wir aber irgendwas. Dann machen wir aber irgendwas, das Podcast-Ufo war. Ich kann mich noch erinnern, du hast damals gesagt, wir können ja auch im Podcast-Ufo über Sugarbabes reden. Niemand hindert uns daran. Das verbietet uns ja niemand.
Und das war für dich der Grund zu sagen, ja, okay, dann machen wir einen Podcast.
Genau, das war für mich der springende Punkt, wo ich gesagt habe, ja stimmt, du hast recht.
Ja genau, weil du einen Monat warst du sauer, hast gesagt, dann willst du mich nicht mehr sehen
und willst auch das Wort Podcast nicht mehr aus meinem Mund hören.
So, dann habe ich gesagt, nee, pass auf, aber musst mich auch dazu aufraffen,
wir können auch im Podcast-Ufo über Sugar Babes reden und dann hast du gesagt, ja, okay.
Das war für mich das Argument, wo ich gesagt habe, ja, guter Punkt. Hättest du dieses Argument nie gebracht, zählen wir nicht hier und würden nicht in diesem Raum frieren jetzt. Und frören nicht in diesem Raum. Ich finde Konjunktive ja toll. Och, ehrlich. Und obwohl ich es nie benutzt habe, es klang irgendwie richtig, auf eine akademische Art, klang es richtig. Ich glaube, Konjunktive sind auch das Einzige, was Umlaute noch haben, wenn wir mal ganz ehrlich sind. Weil wir leben in einer Zeit der Anglizismen, des Englischen, damit fallen die Umlaute zwangsläufig raus. Die gibt es ja nur in, also nicht in der englischen Sprache. Das heißt, das einzige, was die armen Umlaute noch haben, sind die Konjunktive. Weil zum Beispiel ich twitsche. Und jetzt kannst du aber konjunktiv sagen, ich twetsche. Nee, genau. Täte ich twetschen. Twetschte ich heute. Und du hast trotzdem noch das Öl gerettet im Umlaut und dann so heute täte ich twetschen. Aber da hast du noch die Umlaute mit drin, selbst bei Anglizismen hast du da noch eine Möglichkeit. Findest du auch, wir machen es das so einfach bei Anglizismen, dass wir denen einfach immer die einfachste deutsche Konjugation mitgeben? Ja, ne, finde ich nicht, ich finde das genau richtig. Twitche ich heute, ne, das wäre ja... Ne, twetsche ich heute. Ja, genau, deswegen, ich finde nämlich, wir machen es uns zu einfach, weil wir das nie so sagen, wenn wir sagen, twitche ich heute... Twitche er, wäre er noch am Leben. Genau, das ist doch viel geiler. Lass uns doch bei Anglizismen nicht den einfachsten Weg nehmen, sondern da zumindest noch die Umlaute retten. Ja, ich glaube, das braucht jemand, du arbeitest ja immer noch am Knigge, lass uns da einfach mal die wirklich definitive Anglizismen-Konjugationstabelle machen. Einfach er, sie, er ist twitscht, wir twitschen, er twitscht, er hätte getwitscht, er wäre getwitscht worden, sowas. Einfach, dass man das einfach mal klar aufgeschrieben hat. Vor allem nicht immer, das ist das Dümmste, wenn dann Leute sagen, mit der i-d-Endung, also er twitcht und dann hast du die i-d-Endung. Das nimmt ab mittlerweile zum Glück, weil das ja von hinten bis vorne keinen Sinn ergibt, die englische Vergangenheitsform. Wie schreibst du denn R, C, S, designt gute Konzepte? Mit T am Ende. Design und dann T. Das T, das ist ja ein gedeutetes Wort, da brauchst du nicht dieses E, D, das ergibt keinen Sinn. Aber auch da braucht es klare Ansprechen. Naja, es ergibt wirklich keinen Sinn, ne? Ne. Weil es im Englischen gibt es das ja nicht. Du brauchst eine klare Ansage. No, it's designed by. Na ja, na ja, na ja, gut, es macht schon Sinn, also es ergibt, sorry, Jesus Christ, egal, mittlerweile ist es wie so ein Minenfeld, was du um uns herum aufbaust. Ich? Ja. Nee, ich bin total lax. Nee. Ich bin L-A-X-14-Punkte, ich bin total entspannt. Macht den ergibt Sinn. Nein, geht? Hört mal nach, Folge zwei oder drei Podcast-Ufo war es direkt irgendwie. Gut, nehme ich zurück. Ja, nee, weil damals schon so ein Thema. Nee, dann mache ich Kehrtwende. Wir müssen da entspannen. Nee, ich bin absolut entspannt. Das ist mein Ja der Toleranz. Alles geht, alles ist in Ordnung. Von daher, jeder kann sagen. Vor allem auch da macht ja inhaltlich keinen Unterschied. Ich sage immer, du kannst sagen, zwei plus zwei macht vier oder zwei plus zwei ergibt vier. Und damit ist ergeben und machen einfach das Synonym. Deswegen kannst du beides sagen. Also ich entschuldige mich für meine Pedanterie in der Vergangenheit. Ich nehme das zurück. Ich bin offen gegenüber neuen Dingen in der Sprache. Okay, cool. Das ist auch gut, dass man irgendwie charakterlich an sich arbeitet. Ja, absolut. Alle machen Sport und arbeiten an ihrem Körper oder so. Wer arbeitet von euch an seinem Charakter? Sag mal ganz ehrlich. Sag mal ganz ehrlich. Mal Hände hoch, mal Hände hoch. Beide Hände hoch. Alle mal kurz aufhören irgendwie mit diesem Ding, die ihr nebenbei macht. Ihr macht gerade wahrscheinlich irgendwie Sport oder Schlaf, versucht einzuschlafen oder spült. Versucht mal den Einschlafprozess aufzuhalten. Ne, jetzt mal kurz einfach mal Hände so nebenan baumeln lassen, mal aufrecht hinsetzen kurz und mal einmal kurz Hände hoch. Wer arbeitet gerade aktiv an seinem Charakter? Ihr arbeitet an eurer Bildung, an euren Schulabschlüssen, an eurem Körper, wie gesagt, alle versuchen das Leben zu optimieren. Und wenn ihr euch gerade nicht meldet, was glaubt ihr, wer ihr seid? Was glaubt ihr, wer ihr seid? Was glaubt ihr, ihr glaubt, ihr habt den perfekten Charakter oder was? Ja. Ihr glaubt, alle in eurem Umfeld, ja der müsste aber echt ein bisschen zu früh oder spät kommen. Glaubt ihr seid die einzigen, die nicht an eurem Charakter arbeiten müssen? Nein. Nein, gerade ihr. Gerade ihr. Ihr seid nämlich ignorant und da kann man mal anfangen. Wenn ihr denkt, ihr habt keine Fehler, seid ihr ignorant. Wer denkt, wer hat keine Fehler, ja. Selbstbesessen, arrogant und self-centered assholes. Ja. Jetzt könnt ihr die Hände wieder runternehmen. Jetzt könnt ihr, die Hände wieder runternehmen, ihr hättet auch vorher schon gekonnt. Ihr habt vor allem alle viel zu kurze T-Shirts an. Das ist nicht gut für die Nieren alles, das ist einfach viel zu viel Fleisch. Ich mache auch immer den Armhochtest im Laden, wenn ich etwas anprobiere. Weil du überfallen wirst. Den Armhochtest, einfach um zu gucken, ob das T-Shirt nicht einfach zu kurz ist. Und in den meisten Fällen ist es zu kurz. Bin ich ganz ehrlich. Mein Oberkörper ist stretch long. Und wenn ich die Arme hoch mache, ich brauche M lang. Das ist meine Größe, M lang. Weil es ist albern, Grössen sind albern. Ich habe jetzt auch so ein Hosenproblem neues entdeckt, weil ich habe jahrelang 31, 34 gekauft, 34 aber zu kurz. Weil ich habe mich irgendwann geärgert, dass alle Hosen zu kurz sind, bis mir aufgefallen ist, dass es wahrscheinlich einfach die falsche Größe ist, aber 31, 36 gibt es einfach nicht zu kaufen. So, und jetzt könnt ihr, wer ist nochmal als Arm hoch, wer von euch Hosen verkauft, weil da oder schneidert, das ist noch schlimmer, euch gucke ich an. Die Größen sind nicht mitgewachsen mit uns Menschen.
Ja, aber dann würde sich doch so eine Hip-Hop-Phase anbieten, wo du die Hose einfach ein bisschen tiefer trägst. Ist das nicht eine Lösung? Weil du in deiner New Orleans Jazz-Phase, wo irgendwie alles fein säuberlich ordentlich sitzt, ist auch nicht ideal. Ah, meine Fliege sitzt toll. Die sitzt richtig toll. Das machst du richtig gut. Meinst du, das ist ein kleines Gusto-Stückerl für Leute, die andere bedrohen und überfallen, wenn sie sagen, Hände hoch, die sich dann kurz freuen, wenn die Hände hoch waren und dann kurz bauchfreu dastehen und man einfach völlig schutzlos ist in dem Moment, einfach sowohl modisch als auch von der Selbstverteidigung her ist man einfach ausgeliefert. Naja, also ich hab mal, es gab mal zu dem komischen Moment, kam es mal beim Banküberfall, alles war ganz schrecklich, Frauen und Kinder wurden vor meinen Augen erschossen und dann Pistole auf mich gerichtet, Hände hoch und ich habe halt dieses Grinsen im Gesicht gehabt und habe mich einfach gefreut. Warum? Weil man ein T-Shirt perfekt sah. Ja, das ist so wie man es. Und auch in den Bankräuber, wo noch der Blut quasi in seinem Gesicht war, musste auch, konnte nicht anders als mich, als zu sagen, das ist ein sehr gutes Shirt. Ich habe gesagt, danke. Dann hat er gesagt, wo hast du das denn gekauft? Und dann habe ich es erzählt. Weißt du, also das führt manchmal zu schönen Momenten, wenn man einfach ein gut sitzendes Shirt hat. Deswegen Tipp, immer wenn ihr in die Bank geht, noch mal T-Shirt in die Hose stecken, noch mal gucken, könnte ich jetzt die Hände hochnehmen. Auch an alle Bankbewerbsen. Ist wahrscheinlich auch in der Bankkaufmann-Ausbildung ganz wichtig mit dabei, steckt eure Hemden richtig in die Hosen rein, damit ihr im richtigen Moment die Hände hochnehmen könnt. Ja, ich habe auch jetzt Weihnachten erfahren, dass meine Tante, die bei der Bank arbeitet, schon mal bei einem Banküberfall präsent war. Wirklich? Im Raum war. Wow. Und sie hat einfach so getan, als würde sie weiterarbeiten und nicht mitbekommen, was vorne passiert. Und in dem Moment kam eine Kollegin zu ihr, hat gesagt, Frau XYZ, da vorne ist ein Banküberfall. Und sie so, Jesus, ja, ich wollte da jetzt nicht so, ich wollte einfach hier sitzen und so tun, aufgeregt haben. Ich wollte einfach totspielen. Ja, ich wollte, das ist wie, wenn man sich totstellt über einen Camping-Trip, weil ein Bär kommt und dann kommt so ein Kollege, mit dem man diesen Camping-Trip macht. Herr Tietze, da ist ein Bär. Stefan, der Bär! Und man sagt so, halt deine Fresse, ich stelle mich tot! Und das war problematisch, aber es stellt sich raus, dass irgendwie wird dann Geld rausgegeben, was nach ein paar Stunden die Farbe ändert und einfach blau anläuft oder pink. Und dann wird jeder Schein zu einem Fünf-Euro-Schein. Genau. Und dann hat man einfach nur ganz wenig geklaut. Die Zahlen ändern sich. Zu einem Einen-Euro-Schein. Und dann hat man einfach nur ganz wenig geklaut. Die Zahlen ändern sich. Und dann hat man einfach nur ganz wenig. Und dann hat man einfach nur ganz wenig. Das war ja, wenn sie einen ganzen Euro-Schein haben. Also die haben dann eine separate Box mit Fake-Geld. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das jetzt alles sagen darf, weil jeder Einbräger oder Bankräuber, der zuhört, sagt, geben Sie mir Ihr Geld, aber bitte nicht das Fake-Geld. Nein. Denn die werden jetzt sagen, gut, dann befalle ich keine Banken mehr. Was ist der Einfluss, den wir haben wollen? Ob wir darauf, genau, nur weil man es kann, heißt ja nicht, dass man es muss jetzt, dass man da Einfluss nimmt. Ich glaube, wenn du Bankangestellter bist und du hast ja diesen Sack voller Fake-Geld, wo du weißt ... Aber woher weiss das Geld, ab wann der Timer losgeht?
Das Geld weiss es. Es weiss es. Aber woher ... Es weiss es. Wenn ich das rausgebe, woher weiss es, dass jetzt der Timer losgeht, dass es in einer Stunde die Farbe ändert? Warum hat es nicht schon vor einer Stunde die Farbe geändert? Es weiss es. Ist es wie diese Knicklichter, wo man so in der Mitte einmal aktivieren muss oder was? Oder werden die gekühlt? Naja, also, wenn du einen Geldautomaten überfallst, fällst, überfieltest, dann würde da drin, wie in Da Vinci Code, Sakrileg, würde so eine Tinte ausgeschüttet werden. In jedem Bankautomaten hast du so eine Patrone. Bei grossen Erschütterungen wird das dann freigesetzt und das Geld ist wertlos. Slash blau. Was die wertloseste Farbe ist, die wir kennen. Wo man sich als Sparkasse darauf geeinigt hat, die allerwertloseste dumme, also mein Vorschlag damals war braun im Meeting, aber alle haben gesagt, na, blau. Und dann war es aber halt der Kollege mit dem grössten Einfluss irgendwie, mit dem grössten Peer Pressure. Der die rote Krawatte getragen hat, gesagt, nee, so machen wir es. So machen wir es jetzt. Naja, es wurde dann halt blau gewählt. Ich verstehe es nicht so ganz, wie es mit dem Fake-Geld ist. Also es gibt wahrscheinlich Fake-Geld, was rausgegeben wird. Man wird aber echtes Geld rausgegeben in sowas wie Koffern, die aber auch das gleiche dann irgendwann auslösen können. Gibt es da nicht auch so ein Coaching für Bankräuber, was genau die machen müssen und die ganzen Tricks oder so? Sind nicht Bankräuber auch Bankangestellte? Ist das nicht viel einfacher zu klauen, wenn man die Tricks alle kennt? Ja, man erkennt dich ja. Ja, oder das ist bei der Bankkaufmannslehre, sieben die ganz genau aus, dass sie genau wissen, wenn du die falschen Fragen stellst, dann bist du rausgeschmissen aus der Bankkaufmannslehre. Woher weist das Geld, dass es anfängt zu zählen? So, das war's mit den Nichtbestanden fünf. Aus, nehmen Sie sich einen Knicks, nehmen Sie sich noch einen Kugelschreiber und raus hier. Nee, aber ich finde das spannend. Also vor allem, wahrscheinlich kriegst du das Geld auch los an Leute. Ja, du musst dann schnell einen Lamborghini kaufen. Äh, ich nehme den, Gabe. Ähm, hier bitte. Ja, wollen Sie sich die anderen angucken? Nein, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Eine kleine Probefahrt? Nee, nee, nee, alles hier. Nein, nee, einfach den jetzt kaufen. Okay, das macht dann 1,4 Millionen. Hier, bitte. Okay, ich muss kurz nachzählen. 20, 40, 60, 80. Das stimmt schon. Ich fahre schon mal los, okay? Nee, Moment mal, ich muss das kurz zählen. 100, 120, 100. Moment mal, Moment mal! Das ist ja alles blau! Kann schon sein. Aber es ist immer noch echtes Geld. Es ist immer blau. Glaubst du, jeder Mensch, der so im Einzelhandel ... Moment mal, was ist das für ein Geld? Das sind echte Geldscheine, wo noch ein Blau-Add-on mit drin ist. Oder ich verstehe es immer noch nicht. Aber vielleicht ist es die Idee, dass man es nicht versteht oder was. Ja, ich glaube das. Wahrscheinlich stimmt das auch gar nichts. Einfach eine Legende, damit man das schnell ausgibt oder so? Ja, vor allem hat meine Tante diesen Tell gehabt. Weißt du, also diesen lügenden Tell. Sie hat immer das gemacht, was sie macht, wenn sie lügt. Aus ihrem Auge geblutet. Weißt du, und dann erkennst du deine Tante am besten. Das können wir jetzt natürlich nicht gut einschätzen Wie le Chiffre hat sie da einfach geblutet und da sieht man das sein, ihr Tell.
Ne, und da hat das vielleicht Lügen einfach Bankangestellte, wobei ich verstehe nicht, warum ich jetzt angelogen werden muss, also ich bin jetzt eigentlich der typische Bankräuber.
Naja, ich sag mal, du hast schon so einen wilden Blick in den Augen.
Bankräuber haben wilden Blick. Der Bankräuber muss ja den Eindruck vermitteln, er ist bereit, das Äusserste zu tun. Ich vermittle den Eindruck, also wäre ich bereit, das Äusserste zu tun? Ja, auch mit deinem gekrümmten Zeige- und Mittelfinger unter dem Pullover würden deine Blicke mir verraten, oh, du bist bereit, das Äusserste zu tun. Der Bankangestellte, der gerade einen Blaubeersaft trinkt und tollpatschigerweise, ach, über das ganze Geld leider, ach blöd, hier haben sie es noch. Ich glaube, es ist wirklich eine Einstellungssache. Der Bankräuber gewinnt ja nur, weil er in dem Moment bereit ist, das Äusserste zu tun, und der Bankangestellte aber gar nicht in der Situation ist, das Äusserste tun zu müssen. Der ist ja gar nicht in dem Adrenalinschub oder in diesem, weißt du, und das ist auch nicht sein Geld. Braucht man überhaupt eine Waffe oder so? Das meinte meine Tante nämlich auch. Man ist ja bereit, quasi als Bankangestellter Geld rauszugeben. Das ist ja dein Job. Es ist erstens eh versichert, zweitens machst du es eh die ganze Zeit schon. Und es ist eh nur Papier. Es ist auf eine Art nur Papier. Und man hat ja auch den Bezug verloren, ein bisschen dazu, so viel Geld in Hand erzielt. Ja, du robbelst ja die Wirtschaft an, wenn da jetzt drei Lamborghinis verkauft werden, ist ja auch nicht schlecht. Es hat viele Forderungen, es ist nicht dein Geld. Aber was ist, also ich meine, ich gehe immer noch davon aus, dass Bankangestellte angewiesen werden, sofort zu kooperieren und sofort Geld rauszugeben. Aber gibt es ein Mindestmaß, was der Bankräuber tun muss? Also wenn der nicht offensichtlich keine Waffe dabei hat und nichts und einfach sagt, Banküberfall, geben Sie mir ihr Geld.
Wie sehr muss der Bankanstalt nachprüfen, haben Sie überhaupt eine Waffe, haben Sie irgendwas dabei?
Und der guckt so im Auto, glaube ich.
Und sehr kooperiert so. Ja, wir können das gerne machen. Es wäre nur super, wenn Sie mir eine Waffe zeigen könnten kurz.
Ja, eine Sekunde. Moment mal, ich habe jetzt nur
ich habe jetzt hier nur diesen
Tennisschläger dabei, weil ich war
gerade beim Tennistraining, damit könnte ich ihn
ordentlich einen über die Rübe versetzen.
Ah nee, das tut mir leid.
Das reicht nicht. Ich brauche irgendwas, was mich
doller verletzen könnte. Ähm, Sekunde,
ich habe mein Auto steht. Sie können mir auch einfach den
Ausweis hier lassen. Ja. Ich gebe Ihnen schon mal
das Geld und Sie zeigen mir einfach einen spitzen Gegensatz nach. Dann machen wir es so, dann komme ich morgen nochmal und dann machen wir das alles. Alles klar, dann haben Sie hier schon mal. Wie viel wollen Sie denn haben? Dann nehme ich, nehm ich denn, ich würde gerne. Die meisten nehmen immer so eine Million mit. Eine Million, ach nee, also das glaube ich braucht es gar nicht. Ich glaube so 700.000 reicht. Ich würde gerne einen Heistoffballon mir leisten und einen Porsche Cayenne. Es sind mindestens 800.000. Ja, das ist eine minimale Abgabe. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das alles ausgegeben... Ich gebe Ihnen erstmal die jetzt mit. Dann geben Sie mir die 700.000 und dann komme ich morgen noch mal. Und Sie kommen morgen noch mal rein und zeigen mir den spitzen Gegenstand. Wunderbar. Am besten wäre eine Kanone. Okay, wo kriege ich denn eine Kanone her?
Das kann ich Ihnen jetzt auch nicht sagen.
Haben Sie da jemanden an der Hand?
Ich fände es super, wenn Sie nachher,
wenn ein anderer Kollege morgen da ist,
irgendwie gut über mich sprechen.
Okay, kein Problem.
Mich bei der Umfrage, die Sie später auf der Mail bekommen,
irgendwie gut bewerten.
Mache ich, Frau Bärenbach.
Frau Bärenbach, genau.
Alles klar, gut, wunderbar.
Dann haben wir es, bis morgen. Tschüss. Der nächste Tag. Ihre Kollegin hat mir gestern Geld gegeben, das ist alles eingeblaut. Ich konnte keinen Heissluftballon kaufen, ich konnte nichts damit kaufen, es ist alles blau, schau uns nicht mal an. Ah, okay, dann können Sie sich hier bei dieser Beschwerdenummer melden. Dankeschön. Vielen Dank. Ich möchte mich
negativ über Ihre Kollegin Bärenbach äussern.
Oh, das ist aber jetzt.
Jetzt geht es aber ein bisschen zu weit.
Sie ist eine ganz tolle Mitarbeiterin,
die ist noch nicht so lange hier, gerade ihre Ausbildung
gemacht. Ja, aber wenn alles blau wird.
Was glauben Sie, wer Sie sind?
Entschuldigung. Nee, Sie gehen jetzt aus dieser Bank
raus. Tschüss, schönen Tag.
Okay.
Auf morgen! Ich glaube, ich würde mich nicht auf den Boden legen. Ich würde mich zu tun so hinsetzen oder so, aber ich lege mich doch nicht auf dem Boden mit meinem Pullover. Das ist wie bei diesem Song, ne? Down, down, down, down. Die ersten drei gehen alle noch mit. Wo ich immer so an die ersten drei Takte so ein bisschen down gehe, aber dann mehr meine Handbegungen so tun, als würde ich noch down gehen.
Ja, ja, ja.
Aber es reicht, es reicht, es reicht. Ich bin zu alt dafür, immer noch am Boden zu gehen. Da ist es zwei Arten von Leuten, die, die versuchen, die ersten Downs zu skippen und so noch den Drinkwerk stellen, so jetzt gehe ich richtig down, aber währenddessen schon die ersten drei vier downs verpassen oder die die gegen Ende sagen aber es geht nicht mehr schlimmste also Konzerten immer dieses hinsetzen da müssen sich alle hinsetzen ja ja ja ja doch doch doch doch doch bei dem Agnes Obell Konzert wo ich war musste das niemand machen bei dem Ärzte und Beatsex Konzert wo ich war musste man das jeweils machen und dann muss man sich hinsetzen und dann geht der Song los beim Drop und dann springen alle auf und Bier fliegt durch die Gegend und ich dachte mir, können wir uns alle entspannen, ich will nur ein bisschen Musik hören, ich will mich nicht hinsetzen. Anlehnen, anlehnen, bequem machen, bequem machen, jeder wie er will, jeder wie er will.
Einfach Punk ist auch nicht mehr das, was es mal war. Nee, Punk ist aber viel gut, Punk ist viel gut. Punk ist, jeder macht, was er will. Nee, das war anstrengend. Ich würde mich auch nicht hinsetzen, wenn so eine Knarre auf mich. Ich denke aber auch, ich würde, deswegen meine ich Bankangestellte, wenn es um deren eigenes Geld gehen würde, glaube ich, würden sich verteidigen. Und sobald es darum geht, fremdes Geld wegzugeben, stückweit Genugtuung, es geht ja auch mehr darum, einfach so zu überleben und dann diese Story auch zu erzählen. Die meisten Mitarbeiter hassen ja ihren Arbeitgeber, das muss man mal ehrlich. Die sagen, ja, nimm du Scheiß Geld, scheiß Reife. Ich gebe noch mehr. Ich gebe noch mehr. Nimm hier, wirf das Geld ins Gesicht. Gesicht. Du kannst ja in dem Moment dir selber auch was einstecken. Das habe ich auch gedacht. Weil das ist ja genau der Moment, wo du selber als Bankangestellter Geld klauen kannst. Und zwar gibst du dem Räuber das Räuber, auch gutes Wort, was auch ein bisschen verharmlos, du gibst dem Räuber das Falschgeld und dir das echte Geld steckst du dir ein. Das ist genial. Und dann behauptest du nachher, der hätte mehr geklaut, das Doppelte geklaut. Das ist genial. Ja. Genial ist auch die Stelle im Podcast, die ich mittlerweile sehr, sehr gerne mag. Das ist mittlerweile meine Lieblingsstelle im Podcast, und zwar ist es die Stelle, Stefan Tietze hat komplett die Hausaufgaben vergessen. Ich hasse diese Stelle des Podcasts. Was habe ich vergessen? Was habe ich vergessen? Ja, wir haben nämlich wieder Hausaufgaben aufgegeben an euch, die ihr dankenswerterweise erfüllt habt. Ja, ich weiß nicht mehr. Warum guckst du mich jetzt an und redest nicht mehr weiter? Weil du wissen willst, ob ich mich noch ein bisschen daran erinnern kann. Kann ich mich nicht. Keine Erinnerung. Ich weiß nicht, was wir aufgegeben haben. War es was mit diesen Snacks, die man bestellt beim Netflix gucken? Nee. Aber ist denn einer deiner Vorsätze fürs neue Jahr, dich besser an die Hausaufgaben zu erinnern oder? Nee, nee. Gar nicht? Nee, ist nicht drin. Aber ich schreibe es auf die Liste, ich schreibe es unten auf die Liste. Ich habe keine Erinnerung mehr an die Hausaufgaben. Problem aber, ne, Flonten tut es dir so, als wäre er so ein Gedächtnispalastkünstler. Nein, Flonten ist einfach der einzige mit Mailzugang, weil er mir den nicht zur Verfügung stellen kann. Weil ich zu inkompetent bin, das Passwort zu rekonstruieren. Ja, das ist ja mein Vorwurf. Ja. Also, aber hast du grob eine Ahnung, grob eine Idee? Schätz mal, irgendwas, was könnte die Hausaufgabe gewesen sein?
Die sollten aufhören, Ehrchen zu schreiben und mal lieber am Anfang irgendwie Emoji. Nein, also es geht zum Beispiel vielen, vielen Dank an Jojo, der die Hausaufgabe hervorragend erfüllt hat, zwar sehr kurz schon nach der Aufgabe, und zwar es ging darum, uns einen Trailerentwurf für einen Colorado-Film zu schicken. Trailerentwurf? Ja, Trailerentwurf. Also ich erinnere mich an Folgendes, um auch kurz die neuen Hörer mit ins Boot zu holen, Hörerinnen.
Wir wollten ja ein neues Franchise starten, ein cooles neues deutsches Franchise, mal Dinge verfilmen, die, wie damals wurde auch Cluedo verfilmt, guter Film, Clue, kann man auch gut zu Weihnachten immer so rumgucken, könnt ihr jetzt mal noch gucken, kalte Jahreszeit. So, wir wollten aber mal ein geiles neues Franchise und gucken, wo liegen so deutsche Serien vielleicht.
Auch Furtick Riebig basiert ja auch auf einem Disney-Ride. Warum nicht mal da sowas suchen und da fiel uns ein Colorado, weil es auch fucking schwierig ist, aus dieser Colorado-Haribo-Kiste mit den ganzen Sachen, die es da so ringgibt, ein geiles Franchise. The Haribo Universe, das könnte das nächste Marvel werden, weil da gibt es viele interessante Figuren, viele Storylines. Das Haribo Cinematic Universe. Wäre perfekt eigentlich, könnte man gut machen. Und den ersten Schritt liefert vielleicht Jojo, der uns Colorado einen Trailer geschrieben hat. Erstes Bild. Vogelperspektive einer nebelverhangenen Stadt, gegebenenfalls London. 1950er Jahre, Sonnenaufgang. Das rote Gummibärchen kommt aus einer Metallschmelzerei. Es wischt sich Russ aus dem Gesicht, die schwere Arbeit in der Nachtschicht steckt ihm noch in den Knochen. Es macht sich auf den Weg nach Hause, doch an einer Strassenecke lungern drei Lakritzwürfel, die gestreiften. Von diesen Gaunern sollte man besonders nachts lieber Abstand halten. Aber das rote Gummibärchen schafft es ungesehen, durch eine Seitenstrasse vorbeizukommen. Das Bärchen ist fast zu Hause angekommen und sieht die Eingangstür, steht offen. Nichts Gutes ahnend rennt es hinein und findet die Wohnung chaotisch durchwühlt, als ob ein Kampf stattgefunden hat. Panisch schaut sich das Bärchen um, ruft, gelbes Bärchen, wo bist du? Doch es kommt keine Antwort. Das rote Bärchen will Ratsuchen vom weisen, weissen Bärchen. Also eilt das rote zum... Weil er am ältesten ist, weil er nie angefasst wird. Ja, weil niemand will. Niemand isst ihn, deswegen will er am ältesten, slash am weisesten. Am ältesten oder am härtesten, die Weissenbärchen.
Und auch so ein bisschen so eine Hommage an Gandalf, den Weissen.
Gut.
Also eilt es zum weisen, weissen Bärchen.
Also eilt das Rote zum Papp, wo das Weisse eigentlich immer am gleichen Tisch sitzt.
Doch der Türsteher, die Ananas, lässt ihn nicht hinein. Das ist sicher auf Anweisung der reichen Schaumgummiautos. Diese Drogendealer haben bereits die Lakritz-Vierecke gegen die Gummis aufgebracht, um ihr Mafia-Reich zu vergrössern. Oh, mal Lackritz gegen Gummi finde ich fantastisch! Jetzt spalten sie also auch noch die Gummis in verschiedene Lager. Wird es das rote Bärchen schaffen, das gelbe wiederzufinden? Und auf welcher Seite steht dessen alter Rivale das grüne Gummibärchen? Das ist der Trailer, der viel auch auf Textebene arbeitet, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Das wäre jetzt erst mal ein Feedback, was allein das Drehbuchschreiben angeht. Ja, allein der Satz, von dem man sich in der Nacht eher fernhalten sollte, will ich mal sehen, wie der Schauspieler, die Schauspielerin, der Lakritzwürfel es transposiert bekommt, dass man sich in der Nacht lieber von ihnen fernhalten sollte. Ist es CGI, ist es Stop Motion, wie ... Nee, so wie Cats, habe ich mir das vorgestellt, wie dieser hässliche Cats-Film. Also du meinst so Kostüm-CGI-Mischung-Hybrid?
Ja, so eine eklige Kackmischung.
Richtig ekelhaft aus.
Ja, ekelig.
Und Haribo, die Haribos werden irgendwie so Scarlett Johansson.
Hat dann so ein normales Gesicht mit so roten, so Twi'lek wie bei Star Wars, so Appendix.
Ekelhaft.
Finde ich gut, aber auch so diese ganze Hintergrundgeschichte, wenn du sagst, die Ananas lässt ihn nicht hinein, das ist sicher auf Anweisung der reichen Schaumgummiautos, wie soll der Zuschauer das verstehen? Also, er wird abgelehnt von der Ananas und das soll dann aufgrund dieses Mafia-Reichs sein, kann man nicht verstehen. Das ist eine Outline für den Trailer. Aber da möchte ich einfach, da möchte ich sehen, woran sieht man das? Woher weiss der Protagonist, dass dieses Mafia-Reich sein, kann man nicht verstehen als Zuschauer. Nein, das ist eine Outline für einen Trailer. Ja, aber da möchte ich einfach, da möchte ich sehen, woran sieht man das? Woher weiss der Protagonist, dass dieses Mafia-Reich entsteht? Aber ansonsten finde ich es gut. Und ja. Aber wo wir jetzt einen Riesenschritt gemacht haben, und was ich gerne fast einloggen würde jetzt für die kommenden Entwürfe, wäre Lakritz gegen die Gummis. Ja. Das finde ich super. Weil das sind ja offensichtlich die beiden grossen, dann haben wir wieder in einem Rassismus-Metapher. Aber Fuck It ist auch ganz gut für diese Filme, für diese Art von Film. Ist immer noch eine gute, tolle Botschaft. Die Gummis gegen die Lakritz-Dinge. Das finde ich super. So, und jetzt kommen wir zu einem Punkt, glaube ich, der deine Idee nochmal vertieft. Denn denk mal drüber nach. Lakritz gegen Fruchtgummi. Welcher Fruchtgummi-Drop fällt einem da ein? Marit hat eine Idee. Und zwar die Fledermäuse, die beides sind. Der Film erzählt die Geschichte der Fledermaus, die zur Hälfte Gummibärchen und zur anderen Hälfte Lakritz ist. Sie fühlt sich nirgends richtig zugehört. Sie begibt sich auf einer Reise durch das Coloradoland und trifft auf diverse Süssigkeiten, die ähnlich fühlen, unter anderem auf die Erdbeere, die von ihren Sorgen erzählt, weil sie weder Gummibärchen noch Lakritz ist, oder die Himbeere, weil sie Innen Gummibärchen ist, von aussen aber mehr Ähnlichkeit mit dem lila umhüllten Lakritz hat, aber mit diesen Stafettenstälbchen ja. Die Fledermaus merkt, dass jeder seine Ecken und Kanten hat und dass das auch gut so ist. Jetzt kann sie glücklich, mit den anderen zusammenleben und ihre Gedanken verschwinden zu wollen, sind weg, da sie merkt, dass niemand perfekt ist und sie gut so ist, wie sie ist. zur Colorado-Packung sind und dadurch natürlich auch am ehesten die Außenseiterpositionen innehaben. Ja, und das gefällt mir genau, weil die halt
beides sind und sich wirklich wahrscheinlich nicht zugehörig fühlen,
aber natürlich spricht es auch selber an,
die Himbeere ist genauso wicked.
Ja, und vor allem
normalerweise die
Fledermäuse, die beißen
sich gegenseitig die Flügel ab,
damit sie zu den Lakritz zählen.
Die wollen nämlich ihre Gummiflügel nicht
haben, weil sie deswegen immer ausgelacht werden und deswegen beißen die sich die, oder lassen sie sich abbeissen, vielleicht gibt es ja die Menschen so als Monster, die irgendwo leben.
Die ab und zu durchs Land ziehen.
Genau, wo so eine grosse Hand manchmal kommt. Und es ist so eine Art Initiationsritus, dass die jungen Fledermäuse müssen sich die Flügel abbeissen lassen, damit sie zur Lakritzgesellschaft gehören können. Aber unser Held, unser Protagonist sagt, nein, diese Gummiflügel gehören zu mir, sind Teil von mir und vielleicht gibt es auch einen Platz für mich in dieser Welt mit Gummiflügeln. Und natürlich ist am Ende die Fledermaus die einzige, die fliegen kann und damit die anderen retten kann, weil sie als einzige Gummibut-Lakritz ist. Ja, das finde ich ganz, ganz stark. Aber jetzt gefällt mir viel mehr als diese eklige Kack-Katz-Richtung. Gefällt mir einfach so eine plain Lego-Movie-artige Welt, wo man quasi so eine Mischung aus animiert und mit den richtigen Dingen, die wir haben. Also vielleicht auch, fände ich auch gut, übrigens so eine Humorrichtung zu haben, so eine Lego-Movie-Meta-Humorrichtung zu haben. Und jetzt haben wir quasi schon Colorado, der Film, der auch im Colorado-Land spielt. Das fand ich auch eine gute Idee, dass man sagt, es spielt wirklich in so einer schönen, vielleicht so Dschungel, sehr farbenfrohe Welt irgendwie. Ja, wo generell die anderen Fruchtkommis, auch die Schlangen, die Fruchtschlangen unterwegs sind oder so, die ganzen Tiere und die Bären oder so ohnehin. Und ich will jetzt nicht zu sehr meinen eigenen Süßigkeiten-Geschmack mit reinschreiben, aber das Lakritzland ist schon eher so Mordor. Und das Fruchtkimmeland ist eher wie so eine wunderschöne tropische Dschungellandschaft. Ich würde sagen, das Lakritzland ist eher so uniformkonformistisch. Alles ist gleich, alles ist schwarz, alle müssen bitter schmecken, wohingegen das Fruchtgummiland ist eher divers, bunt, verschiedene Farben. Die ganze Zeit so eine Musik. Nee, doch, ständig. Sorry, wenn du deinen Fruchtgummigeschmack reinschreiben darfst, dann will ich meinen Musikgeschmack reinschreiben und diesen scheiß Reggaeton-Beat ein für alle Mal verbannen. Aber dein Musikgeschmack ist nur kein Reggaeton, das ist deine Vorgaben. Ja, das ist die einzige Note, die Howard Shaw bekommt. Howard Shaw bekommt einen Note, schreib Soundtrack wie du willst, nur kein fucking Reggaeton-Beat. Wenn einmal... Nein, ich bin raus, ich verlasse den Saal, sofort. Aber das ist gut und alle leben in dieser Lakritz-Welt, alle total uniform, weil man muss ja auf Karriere aussichten, ja du kriegst keinen Job,, wenn du Fruchtgummi hast und deswegen beißen die sich die Flügel ab und so und er entdeckt oder sie entdeckt dann als einzige die wunderbare Fruchtgummi-Welt. Aber es gibt doch diese komischen Steine, die auch weder das eine noch das andere sind, die sind einfach weird, niemand kann die benennen, die haben nicht mal einen Namen, was das ist für ein Stoff Zucker.
Steine?
Ja, es sind so runde.
Ach ja, ja, genau. Die gibt es auch in Cola-Geschmack, das sind die wahrscheinlich am bekanntesten, so Eier, so ovale Dinger. Es sind nicht immer eiförmig, es ist wie so eine Moment, es sind nur von zwei verschiedenen Dingen. Meinst du diese leicht abgerundeten Pyramiden-Klumpen-Dinger? Nee, nee, nee, nee, ich meine diese, die auch keinen Namen haben. Die haben auch keinen Namen, ich meine diese Steine. Diese Kieselsteine, die haben immer die gleiche Form, so eierförmig. Aber es ist auch nicht genau eierförmig, es ist mehr wie so ein ... weil die auf beiden Seiten so abgerundet sind. Warte mal, welche meinst du? Ja, so, die meine ich auch ein bisschen. Ja, das sind nicht der Fetten. Das hat diese Dinger. Wie beschreibt man das? Sieht einfach aus wie Steine. Es ist nicht ganz ein Kreis. Aber ich glaube, das sind die, die ich auch meine. Weil die sind auch flach auf einer Seite. Die sind flach auf einer Seite. Ja, das stimmt. Wir meinen die gleichen. Es sind die Brockenklumpen, die einfach keiner mag. Und das sind die Bösewichte oder was? Oder die, die? Nee, das sind für mich wie die Enns, die man so dazu bekommen muss. Wo am Ende die meisten Szenen rausgeschnitten werden, weil man bei der Marktforschung merkt, die interessiert keine Sau. War das so? Ja. Hä, ich bin die am besten. Von Baumbart wurde super viel rausgeschnitten. Mein Kommentar in der Marktforschung wäre viel mehr Enz. Und dann würden alle nicht wissen, was sie mit meinem Kommentar anfangen sollen, weil die anderen aus der Marktforschungsgruppe gesagt haben, weniger Enz. Nee, weil es gibt eine Szene, wo Baumbart mit Marion Pippin durch den Wald läuft und denen die Geschichte der Enz erzählt. Und die schlafen ein. Und weil das so langweilig ist. Und dann dachten sie sich im Schnitt, ja, aber die Zuschauer werden auch einfach einschlafen, weil es ist ja langweilig. Das ist zwar die Idee der Szene, aber es ist trotzdem noch langweilig. Und dann haben sie einfach rausgeschnitten. Weil das natürlich immer so dieses, ja, das ist ja die Idee, dass es langweilig ist, aber das hilft ihr ja nicht. Weil es trotzdem ist still boring as fuck. Nee, aber das ist, nee, ich stelle mir die nicht vor, wenn die sprechen müssten, würde ich mir die so vorstellen. Das ist so kleine Bälle, so haben wir das hier schon immer gemacht. Da wird es auch keine Änderung geben, klonk klonk. Wir haben die erste Entscheidung getroffen. Der grüne Gummibär schmeckt mehr nach Apfel als Limette. Ach, das sind so die Architekten, die alten Weisen, oder was? Ihr seid keine Orks. Ja, wir sind Gummibärchen. Zieht ihr mit uns uns in den Krieg? Das haben wir noch nicht besprochen. Wisst ihr, wir bewegen uns sehr langsam und brauchen lange Zeit, um unseren Rat tagen zu lassen. Aber glücklicherweise sind wir alle noch am Leben, weil niemand uns isst. Seid ihr Fruchtgummi oder der Lakritz?
Das wissen wir nicht. Noch nie hat jemand einen von uns gegessen, daher wissen wir nicht, wie wir schmecken. Wir haben keinen Namen und wir haben keinen Geschmack. Und wir schliessen uns keiner Seite an, wir sind weder Lakritz noch Fruchtgummi. Aber seht ihr denn nicht, dass die Horden die Lakritzarmeen das Land überrennen? Doch, doch, aber dazu müsste ich mich kurz umdrehen. Und es dauert mehrere hundert Jahre. Währenddessen sieht im Hintergrund einfach so eine ... Wer dessen steht ins Pubum einfach alle super gelangweilt, ja wir haben es verstanden stellen so genervt ihre Colorado-Box im Publikum weg auch im Film sieht man auch das Publikum, Marktforschung ey apropos weirde Filme, Leute hast du Matrix gesehen, den neuen Matrix-Film? Nee, noch nicht gesehen. Der Film ist so geil. Geil. Der Film ist so ein Chaos einfach. So ein Hin und Her und also nur ein kleiner Titbit an der Stelle. Man sieht Ausschnitte der alten Matrix-Filme in dem neuen Matrix-Film. Das war, mehr sage ich nicht. Mehr sage ich an der Stelle nicht. Aber das klingt ja fantastisch, das klingt ja absolut fantastisch. Und jetzt, vielleicht geht nicht ins Kino, aber macht, was ihr wollt, aber also der Film ist ein Erlebnis. Es ist wirklich ein Erlebnis. Aber ganz ehrlich, das soll es ja auch sein. Er soll es ja nicht mindblowingly toll wieder Philosophie aufzeigen, nein, es soll ein Erlebnis sein.
Na ja, dann schau mal, was du da rausziehst.
Aber also, ich freue mich darauf, jetzt ins Kino zu gehen.
Nächste Woche besprechen wir den hier in Frankreich. Nehmt euch eine grosse Tüte Colorado mit und lasst euch einfach mal drauf ein. Nächste Woche hier Antenne, ähm, äh, Antennexion, äh, Neon, Neo, sorry, Antenne Matrix. Nächste Woche hier an der Stelle besprechen wir dann in Vorgang. Antenne Bullet Time, sowas. Ich kenne halt jetzt auch nicht alle Filme, bin ich nicht so farb die waren ziemlich textlicher drin, aber ich freue mich sehr auf den neuen Matrix. Nee, es ist überall und nirgendwo. Es ist wild. Ich habe jetzt nämlich zum ersten Mal Cloud Atlas geguckt, die grosse Wachowski-Zeit ist angebrochen, nicht verstanden. Nee, überhaupt nicht verstanden. Aber hier ist auch ein bisschen die Idee des Films, ja. Aber ich hab noch nie so wenig Storylines folgen können wie Cloud Atlas und so. Es gibt manche Filme, wo man das Gefühl hat, du nimmst ein Buch, reisst jede Seite raus, mischt die Seiten einmal durch und heftest die so ab, wie du sie gerade hast, und du liest einfach eine Seite nach der anderen. Und vier Seiten sind bei diesem Prozess auch voll raufgegangen. Ja, absolut. Und teilweise sind noch Seiten irgendwie von Leon der Profi mit drin. Und du liest eine Seite und denkst dir, die Seite an sich ergibt halbwegs Sinn, auch wenn ich die Figuren nicht kenne. Aber dann blätterst du um und denkst dir, was, wo sind denn jetzt wieder? Das habe ich nicht verstanden, also auch gar nicht verstanden. Aber cool, also dann, und ehrlich gesagt, es wirkt wie so eine Parodie auf einen Film. Ja. Weil die Sachen, die die sagen, ergeben ja Sinn, für sich genommen, wie du schon sagst. Die Seite ist eine Buchseite, eine perfectly fine Buchseite. Niemand würde sagen, oh, das ist aber komisch geschrieben. Die Dialoge waren auch aus der Sicht, was ich jetzt so sagen kann, gut. Also sie waren halt all over the place und so, und am Ende kam der Abspann zu einem coolen Song, wo ich dachte, mit dem Kopf nickend, ja, geil, mega, mega cool. Also alles daran sagt, es ist ein Film. Aber es war kein Film auf eine Art, deswegen wirkt es fast wie so eine Parodie. Aber auch hier schon, ich habe dann diesen Film, bevor ich ihn geguckt habe, gegoogelt.
Und wenn bei Bildersuche nicht einfach nur diese Werbestills kommen von dem Film oder des Filmposter, sondern so Grafen, ist es schon ein Problem. Versuche zu erklären. Das will man nicht sehen. Die Google-Anfrage des Films ist ein grosses Anschauplakat, wie Personengruppen zusammenhängen. Maybe it's not for me. Ja, ja. Ausser Primer. Ja, nee, aber ich geniesse diese Filme vor allem. Es gibt bei mir immer den Punkt, wo ich sage, jetzt steige ich völlig aus. Viele Filme, wo ich die Hälfte nicht verstehe, aber manchmal gibt es so einen Punkt, wo ich sage, ich steige einfach aus, ich hänge mich jetzt außen an den Zug dran, aber da macht es mehr Spaß. Ja. Aber ich bin da halt, ich komme nicht mehr ans Ziel, vergiss es,
ich werde irgendwo von irgendeinem Masten weggeschleudert vom Zug,
ich werde irgendwo aufwachen, wo ich nicht sein will,
aber für die Zeit macht's
Spaß.
Okay,
oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh,
es klingt immer, er hat einen ganz ungesunden Husten.
Hier ist mir gerade irgendwas einfach in den Rachen gefl ist mir gerade irgendwas einfach in Rachen geflogen.
Ist was in Rachen geflogen?
Einfach aus ganz weiter Distanz richtig in Rachen reingeflogen.
Um zwei Ecken kenne ich Lana Wachowski.
Wirklich?
Ja, genau, weil die liebe Laura, die bei uns Script Continuity gemacht hat, am Set von How to Sell, die auch da bestimmt schon mal über den Weg gelaufen ist. Das ist nämlich dieser tolle Job, wo man darauf achten, wo man alle Kameraeinstellungen aufschreiben muss, darauf achten soll, dass das Hintergrund alles passt, Anschlüsse passen, Einstellungen passen und so. Und auch schon für den Schnitt quasi vorbereitet, also für die Editoren schon so Listen schreibt, was präferierte Takes waren und so weiter.
Und sie machte diesen gleichen Job auch für Lana Wachowski häufig. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie in der Matrix beteiligt war, ich glaube nicht, sondern weil sie der schlimmste Job schon zugesagt hat. Ja genau, und sie muss Entscheidungen treffen. Und von ihr kriege ich immer die schlimmste Mail, immer quasi wenn man eine Staffel dann geschrieben hat, kommt von ihr dann immer eine Mail, die komplett in rot geschrieben ist, wo sie nach Uhrzeiten fragt und so. Wenn sie aber nach einer Uhrzeit fragt, ist es basically eine Suggestivfrage im Sinne von, hier macht was timeline-mäßig überhaupt keinen Sinn. Und wer das für Matrix machen muss, holy shit, vergiss es. Wir hatten in Staffel drei diese eine Montage, wo Moritz, Dan und Lenny einen Drogensack klauen von den Holländern. Und es ist eine lange Montage, wie Leute die von A nach B bringen und quasi niemand in der Kette weiß, wer noch beteiligt war, aber viele diesen Sack von A nach B bringen. Und diese Montage hat bei allen so viele Fragen ausgelöst, dass ich nicht weiß, wie Filme wie Tenet überhaupt entstehen können. Diese Montage hat so viele Probleme verursacht und dass ich am Ende nicht mehr bereit war, Leuten zu erklären, wie es gemeint ist, sondern nur. Einfach, wenn man rekonstruieren muss, wer wann was macht und wie die dann so. Wer wann wo von was nach bringt, genau. Und wann muss der Sack wie aussehen, wann wurde er geöffnet, wie sieht er da aus. Und das ist einfach schwierig, auch immer so Tagesanbrüche und wie viel Zeit vergeht und so weiter. Und sie hat einen wahnsinnig spannenden Job, aber bei sowas wie alle Lana Wachowski-Projekte, sie hat glaube ich Sense8 nämlich gemacht für Netflix und sie. Und sie meinte, die wäre irre, also die wäre wahnsinnig cool, aber wahnsinnig verkopft und im positivsten Sinne wahnsinnig weird. Krass, also Tenet, glaube ich, wäre für mich der schlimmste Film, wo er einfach sagt, wir hören jetzt hier auf, wir haben keine rote Tinte mehr, das geht so nicht weiter. Ja, und vor allem man fragt sich ja auch, also Christopher Nolan muss ein wahnsinnig, entweder das smarteste Team der Welt haben oder er hat einfach so viel Geduld, es immer allen wieder neu zu erklären.
Weil das Ding ist ja, man will ja nicht, also man will ja manchmal Dinge nicht entzaubern, indem man Autoren und Autoren fragt, wie Dinge gemeint sind. Aber im Filmset kann man das Rücksicht nicht nehmen, weil man muss halt Dinge konkret machen und konkret umsetzen.
Und an irgendeinem Punkt, weil man muss halt Dinge konkret machen und konkret umsetzen.
Und an irgendeinem Punkt, Christopher Nolan muss alles bis
blöd on the nose
erklärt haben, weil sonst kann
der Film nicht stattfinden. Und bei diesen ganzen
Gesprächen wäre ich gerne dabei. Wie haben wir allen Leuten
erklärt, wie diese Scheiße funktioniert, die sich
so ausgedacht hat. Weil die gibt ja keinen
Sinn. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Das Problem werden
wir wahrscheinlich auch haben bei unserem Colorado-Film,
wo sie auch anklopft und sagt,
wie ist das jetzt mit den Fruchtschlangen? Weil die
Vielen Dank. darauf gedacht hat. Weil die gibt ja keinen Sinn. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Das Problem werden wir wahrscheinlich auch haben bei unserem Colorado-Film, wo sie auch anklopft und sagt, wie ist das jetzt mit den Fruchtschlangen? Ihr habt hier geschrieben, die hängen als Deko im Wald, aber gleichzeitig sind sie auch Lebewesen, die sprechen, aber was essen die dann? Ach, keine Ahnung. Und wenn da acht Uhr ist, warum? Ach ja, aber tatsächlich, um das mal zu sagen, wir haben einige Hinweise darauf bekommen, dass College Humor mit ihrem verdammten Collagenhumor leider schon die Idee umgesetzt haben von einem Pen and Paper mit Maskottchen. Maskottchen? Maskottchen, ja. Okay. Mit Tony der Tiger. Aber können wir nicht zumindest in Colorado zumindest mal ein Colorado Pen and Paper machen? Du hast ja eh wieder alles vergessen, aber wir haben auch drüber gesprochen, über ein Pen and Paper von Maskottchen. Ja, das weiß ich noch. Das ist raus, oder wir müssen halt den Teil aus der Folge schneiden und einfach sagen, wir haben es nicht gewusst. Aber Colorado ist auf jeden Fall drin. Aber wir können ja zumindest, wenn der Film nichts wird, können wir ja zumindest ein Colorado Pen and Paper machen.
Das Problem ist halt der Ausdruck von diesen Figuren. Die haben ja keinen Ausdruck, die haben ja keine Gesichter, auch so ein Gummibärchen hat ja, der kann nichts in die Hand nehmen, der kann nichts machen. Jetzt muss man mit deinem Skeptizismus wieder ein bisschen vorsichtig sein.
Wieder ein Gang, also ich würde gerne, wenn du ein Roboter wärst, deine Skepsis runterstellen auf 20 Prozent. Okay.
Wieder ein bisschen hochgefahren im letzten Jahr, weil auch im Lego-Movie haben die das ja hingekriegt. Ja gut, aber die haben zumindest Hände. Ich meine, wir haben hier eine Ananas. Zumindest gebe ich dir recht. Wir haben teilweise hier eine Ananas als Türsteher, der auch noch mit seiner Mimik verraten muss, ich halte dich hier gerade auf, weil die Mafia-Familie hat jetzt Überhand genommen und wir sind in einem Bandenkrieg. Sagt das mal einem CGI-Programmierer, der das designen soll, auf dem Gesicht der Ananas das darzustellen, dass jetzt dieser Plotpunkt rübergebracht wird. Ein Kumpel von mir hat jetzt für Edeka den Weihnachtspot gemacht, wo Tropfengesichter haben, wo im Himmel, in Wolkenstadt, Tropfen auf die Erde fallen, um in der Hoffnung, eine Special Snowflake zu werden. Und das hat sehr gut geklappt. Selbst das sind Regentropfen. Ich will nur mal sagen, Skepsis wieder runter auf 30%. Nochmal, okay. wieder hochgegangen. Ja, sorry. Ich weiß nicht, was da los ist. Aber haben die auch Arme und Beine gehabt? Weiß ich nicht mehr, ich glaube ja. Und die sind trotzdem noch als Tropfen erkennbar gewesen. Und die und Gummibärchen haben ja schon per se Beine. Gut, dann haben sie mich überzeugt, hier sind 100 Millionen Dollar. Bitteschön, ich bin mittlerweile auch sogar relativ halb ernst gewählt, unsere Duftkerzen-Idee umzusetzen. Ich fand die richtig gut mit den Duftkerzen, mit Schichten, auch was Filme angeht und so, also irgendwie zu bestehenden Filmen zu sagen, hey, du bist doch ein Jano-Jones-Fan, hier ist eine Kerze für den ersten, zweiten, dritten Teil, kann man als Komplettpaket verkaufen, 20 Euro Online-Shop, wunderbar. Jetzt gerade zur Weihnachtszeit habe ich gemerkt, wie egal es ist bei Produkten, ob die nützlich sind oder nicht, solange sie gut als Geschenk durchgehen. Aber dann lass uns doch jetzt bei dem Prozess anstoßen. Wie starte ich, das ist auch für alle draußen spannend, sehr spannend, wie starte ich jetzt eine eigene Duftkerze?
Der Prozess startet heute Abend in meinem Wohnzimmer, denn ich mache Test 1. Und zwar das Hauptproblem, auf das ich gestossen bin, ist ja, dass wenn du eine Duftkerze hast mit Schichten, also erst zehn Minuten Vanille, dann zehn Minuten Kirsche, dann zehn Minuten Orange. Indiana Jones 2, wie in Indiana Jones 2. Genau, du hast es erkannt. Das könnte auch ein Partyspiel sein, man macht die Kerze an und versucht an der Kerze herauszufinden, welcher Film es ist. Und jeder hat, sagen wir mal, zehn Versuche, aber mit jedem Versuch kriegt man weniger Punkte. Also wenn du es bei deinem ersten Versuch richtig liegst, kriegst du zehn Punkte, beim zweiten Versuch nur noch neun Punkte. Das heißt, du musst dir überlegen, ab wann mache ich meinen Versuch und so weiter könnte eine Idee sein. Und dann mache ich die Kerze einfach aus, weil es auch nervig wird. Eine Stunde lang hauenbrennende Kerze starren. Gut, aber das ist ja etwas anderes. Es kann ja nebenbei während der Party so laufen einfach. Ich finde das so toll, ich finde das so super. Die Geruchsebene ist ja ohnehin oft nicht besetzt einfach. Und Cloud Atlas wäre die nervigste Kackkerze der Welt.
Und dann nochmal.
Das hat mich so verwirrt, dass du in den Stuhl berühst.
Ich bin so orientierungslos noch in diesem Jahr, dass ich mich acht Minuten umgeguckt habe, was das für ein Geräusch ist.
Aber Cloud Atlas wäre halt, weil du halt alle zwei Minuten in das andere Universum springst.
In dem einen riecht es nach Meerwasser, in dem anderen riecht es nach so Plastik, dieses Neo-Soul oder was das für eine Stadt war, riecht es wahrscheinlich einfach nach Grossstadt, auch viel Spaß mit Luftkerzenfirma B zu sprechen und zu sagen, Grossstadt, Asphalt, ne? Ja. Also das wären bestimmt so 90 Schichten. Denn das Hauptproblem, das ich sehe, ist, dass wenn du erst 10 Minuten Vanille hast und dann kommen 10 Minuten Kirsche, dass ja dann während der Kirsche der Raum immer noch nach Vanille riecht. Das heißt, der Geruch haut ja nicht ab. Und das teste ich heute Abend. Ich kaufe zwei Duftkerzen, mache 10 Minuten die erste an, dann mache ich die erste aus, mache dann die andere an und versuche dann zu riechen, wie der Geruch sich verändert, ob der zweite Geruch den ersten verdrängt oder es sich vermischt, weil das Problem ist natürlich, wenn du am Ende so Cloud Atlas mit zwanzig verschiedenen Gerüchen hast, dann riecht dein Raum am Ende einfach nach zwanzig verschiedenen Gerüchen und du bist nicht nur visuell und auditiv überfordert, sondern auch olfaktorisch und komplett überfordert, weil dein Gehirn 20 verschiedene Gerüche versucht, aus anderen zu halten. Und zu denken, wo sind wir gerade, was ist das, das passt gerade nicht. Also schwierig. Aber wie geil, ne? Filmsense, Filmsense oder so, wäre auch ein guter Moviesense. Weiß ich nicht. Aber was ich total cool finde. Ich dachte an Smeldorado. Smeldorado. Aber ... Nee. Okay. Nee, aber ich fände zum Beispiel den ersten Lord of the Rings Teil super. Also Mordor, glaube ich, schwebt uns beiden so einen Schwefelgeruch vor, so ein anstrengender, in der Nase beißender Schwefelgeruch. Ja. So eine Mischung aus Rauch und Schwefel. Ja. Oder vielleicht noch Kohle. Da hat man ganz viel Wald, ne, Latschen, Kiefer, Fichte, sowas. Genau. Wald, die Waldelben ganz toll, also wirklich super. Und dann hast du natürlich im Bruchtal, hätte ich so einen floralen Cent gern, sowas wie Jasmin. Und dann Achtung, wenn der Ballrock auftaucht, hast du so einen kleinen Böller drin in der Kerze. Und dann so, pfsch, und kurze Wunderkerze, einfach drei Minuten zu spät, während alle traurig sind und weinen, weil Gandalf runtergefallen ist, und dann einfach während Frodos Blick, da musst du halt aufpassen, weil wenn ihr nämlich die falsche Luftfeuchtigkeit habt, dann brennt die Kerze nämlich auch leicht anders schnell.
Also alles ein bisschen schwierig.
Aber da kann man ja noch mal überlegen, wie man das einbaut.
Auenland, welches Auenland?
Ja, Auenland natürlich so ein bisschen, so.
Na ja, nach grünem Gras.
Tabakrauch.
Tabakrauch, so ein bisschen grüner Tobi, nämlich aus grüner Tobi und Gras.
Ja.
Und ein bisschen Pferd vielleicht auch noch mit drin.
Wenn wir von unserem Weinset auch noch ein paar Tröpfchen Pferd mit drin haben, dann kann das da auch noch reinpassen. Pony, ein paar Tröpfchen Pony oder sowas. Und dann hast du natürlich die Edition für den zweiten Teil, die heißt dann Smellagon, wo du halt dann auch viele rohe Fisch-Szenen drin hast. Die ganzen Sachen drin. Ja, der erste Teil heißt Smellon, der zweite Teil heißt Smellagon und der dritte Teil heißt Rückkehr des Dufts. Als Rückkehr des Dufts. Ja, finde ich gut. Nee, ich finde das immer besser. Und wir fangen das mal heute Abend, fängst du bei dem Prozess an. Smellrond hast du auch. Smellrond. Vielleicht kommt der im dritten Teil kurz vor.
Die Smelfen, ja da kannst du viel machen.
Smelben. Da kannst du richtig viel machen.
Ja,
das ist eine gute Idee, aber wie gesagt, es hängt alles an dem Experiment, das ich heute Abend tätigen werde,
nämlich wie verhalten sich Gerüche
zueinander verdrängt. Wir wissen ja auch nicht genau,
was Gerüche sind. Also
so ein Geruch erfüllt ja schon den Raum. Gut, dass wir in alten Raum. Ich habe jetzt erfahren, was Sonnenwinde sind. Und zwar die Sonne ballert ja Licht auf uns in Form von Photonen, aber diese Photonen haben ja auch Kraft, die haben ja auch einen Wehen. Und die Sonne drückt die Erde ein Stück weg von sich. Wie? Dadurch, dass sie die Photonen auf die Erde ballert. Dadurch wird die Erde ein Stück weggedrückt. Und jedes Jahr, so zwei mal zwei Zentimeter oder so, wird die Erde von der Sonne weggedrückt, weil die durch das Licht weggeweht wird in gewisser Weise. Aber ich sehe jetzt nicht viel. Nö. Und müsste sie jetzt auch nicht ausgleichen, weil das Universum quasi nach, ne, also die Zentripitalkraft gleicht sich ja aus mit der Anziehungskraft zwischen Erde. Also aber schon, die Sonnenwinde sind stärker als die Anziehungskraft der Sonne. Das willst du mir ja gerade erzählen. Das willst du mir ja gerade unterjubeln. Nee, das ist ja ein Gleichgewicht. Das ist ja ein Gleichgewicht. Es drückt doch weg, hast du gerade gerade erzählen. Das willst du mir gerade unterjubeln.
Nee, das ist ja ein Gleichgewicht.
Es drückt doch weg, hast du gerade erzählt.
Ja, aber das hat ja nichts mit der Schwerkraft zu tun. Die Schwerkraft hält es ja in einem konstanten Orbit.
Die Schwerkraft zieht ja erstmal die Erde an. Die Schwerkraft der Sonne zieht die Erde zur Sonne.
Ja.
Die Zentripetalkraft hält dagegen. Du willst mir sagen, dass Sonnenwände die Erde wegtreiben und damit stärker sind als die Anziehungskraft? Oder so? Ja, sowas in der Richtung. Es ist eine zusätzliche Kraft, die dazugehört, die nichts mit der Schwerkraft zu tun hat. Wenn es die Sonnenwinde nicht gäbe, würde es sich auch in einem Orbit drehen. Aber du hast halt zusätzlich noch, das ist wie wenn du jemanden an einem Seil hast und dich um dich drehst und ihn dann auch noch anpustest. Also noch eine neue, a new shit in the mix. Neue entdeckt, noch oben drauf. Die armen Achtklässler müssen immer mehr lernen. An der natürlich die naheliegend Idee, wir bauen ein großes Segel, um weiter wegzukommen von der Sonne, um dem Klimawandel entgegenzuwirken. Klar. Aber wir drehen uns halt auch ständig. Das alte Problem. Das ist the old one. Naja, aber dann... Ja, millionenalte Problem der alten Menschheit, dass die Erde sich dreht. Pitch, Kugellager, riesiges Kugellager. Ja, der Film, Kugellager der Film. Kugellager der drei. Sodass das Segel immer an der gleichen Stelle ist in Verhältnis zur Sonne und die Erde wegdrückt ein bisschen. Genau. Oder so ein Fallschirm. Ich habe die ganze Nacht wachgelegen, weil ich mich gefragt habe, wie man sich, ob man es merkt, wenn man genau oben am Nordpol oder Südpol oder unten am Südpol steht. Weil die Erde dreht sich ja. Und wir sind es ja gewohnt zu drehen. Stell dir mal vor, du stehst jetzt ganz oben. Klar, wir sind schräg und so, aber ich meine jetzt da genau die Mitte oben der Rotation. Wo du dich um deine eigene Achse dreht. Dann müsstest du dich ja um deine eigene Achse drehen. Ja. Was verhindert das? Was verhindert das? Was verhindert was? Dass du dich um deine eigene Achse drehst, weil die Erde dreht sich ja relativ schnell auch um sich selbst. Ja, aber die Frage ist, ob du es merkst, dass du dich drehst oder nicht. Ich glaube nicht, weil sich ja die ganze Atmosphäre auch mit dir mitdreht. Ja, ja, genau, du merkst es nicht. Das ist ja nicht wie so ein Karussell. Du merkst es nicht, aber es ist doch hilarious, zu wissen, dass man sich gerade sehr schnell um die eigene Achse dreht. Ja, sehr schnell ja auch nicht. Wie? Naja, halt eine Umdrehung pro Tag. Wenn ich dich auf so einen Plattenspieler stelle, der sich einmal am Tag dreht, würdest du das wahrscheinlich auch nicht erinnern. Aber ich finde es lustig. Du wirst laut lachen. Du wirst laut lachen. Aber du hättest wenig, also als Karussell eher enttäuschend. Die Erde ist ein sehr lames Karussell. Da müsste ich es nicht merken, weil ich ja den ganzen Rest meines Lebens nicht auf einem Plattensteller stand.
Weißt du? Man merkt doch leicht, dass was passiert, dass man sich um sich selber dreht.
In 24 Stunden eine Umdrehung, das glaube ich nicht, dass du das merkst.
Ich meine, wir können natürlich, nein, aber da haben wir jetzt noch die Ralf-Schmidt-Sendung.
Wir haben zehn Promis auf zehn Plattenspielern, fünf davon drehen sich mit der Geschwindigkeit der Erde, die anderen fünf nicht. Und nach einer Stunde müssen die sagen, habe ich mich gedreht, ja oder nein, ob sie es fühlen oder nicht. Okay? Ist das ein Kompromiss für dich? Ja, das ist ein Angebot. Okay. Gut, dann haben wir noch eine Lesung. Ich werde mir die Sendung nicht angucken, sondern mir nachher bei DVDL durchlesen, was passiert ist. Aber, und vor allem wie viele Quoten es gab, sehr spannend. Aber ja, also das würde ich gerne schon mal wissen, wie sich das so verhält. Also weil es kann mir schon, ich habe auch bei Weihnachten, da habe ich mit meiner Familie Trivial Pesuk gespielt und eine Frage war, und da merke ich einfach, dass ich stro-dumm bin, es sind immer die gleiche Art von Fragen, wo ich dann wirklich eine halbe Stunde lang darüber nachdenken muss, die Frage war, was passiert, wenn man nach Osten über die Datumsgrenze geht? Oh Gott! Und dann denke ich mir immer, dann sieht man wirklich so, wie die ganze Welt und alles, was ich mal dachte zu wissen, in sich zusammenfällt, weil ich daran zerbreche, an diesen einfachsten Dingen.
Also im Sinne von geht es einen Tag nach vorne oder einen Tag nach hinten oder sowas?
Ja, man reist einen Tag zurück, aber dann denkt man sich, what the fuck?
Und wenn ich aber lange genug nach Osten gehe, komme ich dann ...
Kannst du ja in der Vergangenheit reisen.
In der Zeitreise?
Ja, genau.
Ist das nicht Superman 3, dass der so ganz schnell um die Erde fliegt, um sie zurückzudrehen? Viel interessanter ist ja, was passiert, wenn du nach Westen gehst. Dann reichst du in die Zukunft. Oder sowas. Oder nicht. Nee, aber ich glaube, die Sonnenwinde wenig. Die drücken dich wieder zurück, ja, ja. Die drücken dich schon in die richtige Zeit, wo du hingehörst. Das ist ja auch der Grund, warum die Zeit von der Vergangenheit in die Zukunft läuft, weil die Winde wissen schon was los. Zum Glück sind die so schlau, nicht, dass die uns mal fragen, Entschuldigung, erwähnen wir noch mal von Ost nach West oder von West nach Ost? Und dann weißt du, es ist vorbei, dieses ganze System bricht in sich zusammen, weil wenn nicht mehr die Sonnenwinde wissen, was sie zu tun haben. Das wäre das auch was von Gott, oder, dass der Engel zu Gott kommt und sagt, Entschuldigung, noch mal mit der Superposition der Quantenteilchen. Wie war das noch mal genau? Sind die jetzt gleichzeitig am selben Ort oder gleichzeitig am anderen Ort? Und Gott so, Alter, ich habe gar keine Ahnung, was ich mir dabei gedacht habe. Ja, mach mal, mach mal so was. Schlag mal was vor. Schlag du mal was vor. Schlag mal was, was würdest du denn machen? Ich habe bis morgen zehn nur was auf dem Tisch. Schick dir was, schick dir was. Wo du gerade bei Engeln warst, ich schaue jetzt mal wieder. Super nett. Super nett. Ja. Und ehrlich gesagt fände ich es immer spannend, selber in der Buchfurt nachzulesen, mein wievielter Anlauf, dass er süder ist, weil ich immer mit der gleichen Staffel wieder neu anfange, die wo die Engel zum ersten Mal auftragen, Staffel vier, jetzt bin ich schon bei Staffel sechs, wird sehr schlecht, aber es wird am, habe ich mal irgendwann so die Beliebtheit bei IMDb sortiert und in Staffel dreizehn, die es jetzt irgendwie gibt, kommen wieder sehr gute Folgen, also ich muss jetzt dranbleiben, wow, da war eine Menge Staffeln dranbleiben. Ja, weil ich in diesem einen Loch immer reingefallen bin und aufgehört habe wieder, und dann muss ich ja Staffel 4 anfangen. Aber jetzt bin ich wieder mega drin in der Lore. Und es ist so geil, was für Einbahnstrassen sich diese Writer auch geschrieben haben. Weil ja immer ... Es war fantastisch. Also, Tod spielt immer keine Rolle mehr, weil alle schon achtmal aus Himmel-slash-Hölle wieder rausgeholt wurden. Dann waren irgendwann die Dämonen, wurden die krassesten Gegner etabliert. Dann kamen irgendwann Engel, die mit einem Fingerschnippen Dämonen killen können. Aber Engel sind ja auf der guten Seite, was ein großes Problem ist, weil jetzt keine Gefahr mehr da war. Da haben sie die Engel schlecht geschrieben und böse geschrieben. Es ist fantastisch und macht sehr viel Spaß zu gucken. Und manchmal, finde ich, braucht man auch so ein bisschen so eine Trash-Serie. Auf jeden Fall, ich schaue gerade das Rad der Zeit. Super. Neue Fantasy-Serie auf Amazon. Ja, genau so wie man es sich erwartet. Genau so wie man es sich erwartet. Rückkehr des dunklen Magiers und alle Teile sind genauso wie das erwartet. Basiert es auf etwas, was man kennt? Romanreihe, glaube ich, irgendwie. Hast du die gelesen? Nö, nö, nö. Aber es ist das, was es ist. Es ist das, was es ist. Ja, aber nee, das ist ja okay. Das ist eh so dieses generisch, warum ist das unbedingt schlecht so? Rom-Coms, da hast du auch immer die gleichen Beats und die gleichen Sachen und dann so bei Fantasy sind dann so die Hardcore-Fans immer so Augen geräumt, schon wieder Rückkehr des dunklen Königs, schon wieder drei auserwählte, so, ja, aber das ist halt eine Chance, das ist halt so. Du hast halt, bei Western hast du halt auch immer den Revolverhelden, so, ist ja auch, das ist halt dasselbe, ich bin da, ich mache ein lockeres Lachs, ja, ich habe keine Ansprüche mehr, ich habe keinen Bock mehr auf dieses ewige, nee, das ist aber schlecht, das hat die Serie schon so gemacht. Mein Gott, ich schaue es mir an, ich versuche das Beste zu haben. Wie viele Jahre haben wir noch ein paar? Ein paar haben wir noch. Da versuchen wir einfach das Beste rauszumachen. Ich schaue bis dahin, bis Supernatural Shuffle 13. Ihr könnt mich nicht aufhalten. Nein. Die einzigen, die schaffen mich aufzuhalten, ist Supernatural, wenn es zu schlecht wird. Und dann frage ich mich auch, was muss passieren? Also weil es war ja nie richtig geil. Ja, das ist der eigentliche Spannungsbogen der Serie ist, wie tief kann ich sinken, dass ich es noch weiter schaue, was muss passieren, wenn ich aufhöre, wie tief sind wirklich meine Ansprüche, was muss passieren, das ist der eigentliche Spannungsbogen. Die einfachsten Dinge helfen aber schon, um mich bei der Stange zu halten, weil dann kamen Erzengel sind dann aufgetaucht. Oh, geil! What yes! Und die sind so stark wie wie viele Engel? Hundert! Wow! Krass! Da war jetzt, da hat man einen Engel schon die ganze Zeit, ist er schon dabei, Castiel, ist die ganze Zeit am Start, und irgendwie fand ich dann, irgendwann hat er seine Kräfte verloren und wurde ein bisschen lame.
Und dann hat irgendwer, hat er jetzt gesagt, du bist kleiner, als ich mir dich vorgestellt habe. Und er sagt, das ist nur meine Hülle. In meiner echten Form bin ich so gross wie euer Chrysler Building. Und ich sofort so, ich habe sofort gedacht, fuck yes. Jetzt kommt die Power Ranger Megazord. Das reicht mir, um jetzt wieder 19 Staffeln Supernatural zu gucken. Das Wissen, dass dieser Schauspieler einen Engel spielt, der in Wahrheit, was man nie sieht, in echter Form so groß wie das Chrysler Building ist. Wie toll. Wahnsinnig konkret. Wie so ein Kind. Wie so ein Kind. So sprechen Engel, so sprechen Engel in der Bibel auch. Das Königreich der Himmel wird so groß wie das Opel-Fabrikhalle. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie lange du noch dranbleibst. Und vielleicht wirst du irgendwann dieses Jahr noch einen Supernatural-Podcast aufmachen. Vielleicht wird dein Fandom noch mal richtig aufblühen. Ich würde es mir freuen. Und ansonsten sehen wir uns nächste Woche wieder, wenn es weitergeht. Denn auch in diesem Jahr, wir machen weiter. Es geht weiter. Wenn ihr euch auf eins verlassen könnt, dann auch das Podcast zufunk. Und ich würde sagen, so neu ist das neue Jahr gar nicht.
Denn wir machen weiter.
Macht's gut.
Auch im neuen Jahr, neben dem Jahr ab.
Ciao.
So heisst es, Burt Production.